are the court system as biased against
men
in the uk as they are in the u.s
yeah is that like a big thing here oh
yeah yeah it's more or less the same we
don't have alimony here i don't know why
that is still a thing over there
why do you guys have why is that even
still a thing that makes no sense to me
i don't i don't get it either like why
why do i get money for being married to
you
that's what it is it's like there's no
kid yeah i don't even really understand
child support either
i get child yeah i get child support you
don't think child people should get
child support i have custody i don't
understand the extreme it's at today we
say the extreme what do you mean like
girls are
taking drake's condoms to get
a bag and like the number one and the
reason that nba players go broke is
getting the wrong girl pregnant
because the way it works the way it
works in the u.s is like it goes off of
your income the year before
yeah that makes sense yeah so if you go
from like making a million to say 250
000 the next year you still have to pay
based on your old income yeah yeah and
it might take a while to get it changed
yeah so then you go broke
yeah and i i just don't understand like
why
like what are you paying for
and shouldn't it start with like being
50 50 like custody well no it's suppose
it's supposed to be
um the
so the
the father
is supposed to the child should be
living a minimum of the highest
lifestyle for whatever parent is
providing that uh-huh
so if the father is living a very lavish
lifestyle
the child who is his blood
should also
be living an equivalent one why
because it's his child
i don't think so that's why you don't
think it's his child
[Laughter]
because for the court it's not going to
the mother it's going to the charge but
obviously everyone knows like if a
woman's getting 10k a month 500 of that
is going to the chart the rest is on her
yeah
and so i don't know how we like prevent
that because i mean i'm not like
i just think it's ridiculous
that like why if you get a kid by drake
why why do you get
such a big percentage of his income
that's nuts well well it's you don't get
a big percentage of the income i i've
heard i think it's big in illinois i i
heard
it's like uh 25 for each kid
or like
this could be wrong but i have a friend
who was like going going through this i
mean i wouldn't say 20 i'd be like yeah
first 24.
if i'm thinking from my child
yeah 20 20 of my income for my child
yeah it's not going to the child yeah
but we call it control about a year
she's 250 000
if that's supposed to be going towards
my child then 100 yeah 100
like whatever the child needs and i'm
the best of but obviously yeah it well
that's
it's not about how much it is it's how
do you regulate how do you make sure
that it's towards the child not the
mother but you can't
that's crazy to me but also as well
here's my argument like okay here's my
question to you do you think if divorce
happens that
as a general rule it should be
prioritized for the child to go to the
father
um i think it should start at 50 50.
okay i think
three days a week each i also think that
you shouldn't be able to move
hmm
i think that's not fair like if one
parent gets a job in another state you
made the kid in that state that's their
home that's where you guys agreed to
raise well unless you have permission
yeah right right permission yeah of
course because i've had this i've had
this um i've had this debate with
um other girls where
you know so i'm like oh justify
the alimony or like the extensive amount
of child support
and she'll be like well what if what if
the woman can't earn enough money to
live now like well the child goes to the
father then
oh yeah
because if she can't provide for the
child
then the child should go to the parent
who can that makes sense
but then we're like no like the child
should be with me even if i can't
provide for it and he should provide
where i like
which i'm a bit like hmm
i don't get that
okay i just don't
i don't know what like other than food
like what are you paying for the rent
the food
yeah
but then at the same time
i don't know maybe maybe i can't say
this because i'm i'm not a father but at
the same time
if you can see your child on the
weekends
and your weekdays you have the freedom
on your weekdays
it's not a bad deal
it's not a bad deal how do you look at
it wouldn't you be sad you don't get to
see yourself like i said maybe i don't
know because i'm not a father
so maybe i'd feel different oh free
babysitter
yeah it's a free bit but it's not free
because you're paying a lot more right
but i'm like well
when i am free i can see my child
instead of having to worry about my
child when i'm not free which i'm like
ah
maybe there's a you know there's another
side to this that we're kind of
neglecting you know it's also crazy that
women get so much lesser sentences for
the same crime it's very true
like we just gotta like bat our eyes at
the judge they're like oh it's okay
what was the female judge probation
i think we all have this natural
instinct to protect girls and i think
girls kind of have it too oh girls have
a natural instinct guys have a natural
instrument to protect girls and girls
have a natural instinct to protect
themselves
but i understand that it's a it's an
evolutionary thing
because
well physically women are
the weaker sex on a general basis
so it was very important for them
their survival came more from
social skills and being selfish
in terms of looking out for their own
needs as opposed to
sacrifice for others that's what men did
that's true but sometimes
it just irritates me because i think
that's why girls get away with so much
stuff
yeah i think it's it's starting to
change though yeah well especially with
the red pill yeah i think i think the
red pill is gonna change a lot of things
oh yeah and men's rights and that's
starting to become more mainstream oh
hundred percent i mean purely because of
red people like less men wouldn't get
married
yeah
that's true or maybe that's the courts
well and it's so
it sucks that it's such a big risk for
guys what marriage yeah because they
could
lose half their money yeah i i had to
have a conversation with my parents and
be like i don't know if i'll actually
ever get married i was like i'll have a
long time partner
but there may never be a wedding for you
to come to when it comes to me
oh my gosh my parents would kill me if i
ever said that
i think of the same thing though
sometimes actually
time's different because
but i'm a woman so i probably i will but
yeah you probably
what as soon as you accept a shorter guy
[Laughter]
all the guys in there they're like yeah
[ __ ] accept it
who are they thinking don't be like all
these other hoes
who like if you're not under 6'3 i don't
even see you
i wouldn't make that card i'm 62. and
i'm like i thought i was tall enough
okay kit
go on am i getting some hate yeah you'd
be talking like a simp sometimes he's an
actual gentleman but where do you draw
the line what do you what do you have to
say to the people that think you're a
stamp
if i own a union that's what i'll say
[Music]
is